you produce you write songs you act you
you do all the things is there anything
left you've had such an illustrious
career like is there anything left that
you want to do that you haven't done yet
um well first of all that was very kind
um it was honest I
I growing up in in the industry and
getting access to so much in the studio
yeah I just became like a studio rat
like I just loved being in there and I
loved the the creative process and and
you know and and also as it pertains to
harmonies um I spent some time with four
other guys doing a lot of harmonies who
who are you speaking
of uh by the way y'all broke the
internet when y'all came back for the
song yeah that was that was fun that was
fun it was kind of crazy like there's so
much that just picks up right where it
left off as far as the chemistry um but
uh
yeah
yes just saying I don't normally I don't
want people to think can what is that
can you see that picture again I don't I
I feel like I have a disclaimer like I
was having a really bad allergy day and
that's why I was wearing the sunglasses
I don't want no um but um yeah we we
we've been in the studio so there may be
a little okay that's what I was going to
ask yeah it's
exciting it's exciting well we need to
get to a few commercials let's pass
things over to Megan hi Kelly and Justin
oh my God Justin that is that I'm sorry
that is jarring I didn't see it I didn't
see it until Jus now Justin I feel like
we already know each other I keep this
cutout in my high school Spanish
classroom you've been my ride or die co-
teer for the last 18 years helping me
Teach Spanish Verbs conjugations
sentences we do it all
baby you even sorry babe you even you
even make sure the kids don't cheat on
tests and and quizzes thank you you're
just
hoing more with Kelly and Justin after
this here's
F you want me to just my name or you
want me to put I love you
Megan I love
you
[Music]
B
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home